and this is the a very sad story of the
Nottingham fire that happened over the
weekend while police in Nottingham have
now confirmed that they are
investigating a triple murder after the
mother who has been in hospital for the
last two days has very sadly died and
she's also been named she's called
fatuma hydrara and she was 28 and the
two children that died Naima drama who
was one and Fatima drama who was three
this is an image of the mum and her two
children the mum who has died and her
two children who died in that fire in
Fair Isle close uh just been announced
by police in Nottinghamshire let's bring
in Midlands correspondent Becky Johnson
who is at the scene for us and Becky
this is an awful story this mum has been
on life support since the weekend but
today it has been announced that along
with her two children she too has
perished
this is just an incredibly sad story
that is now a triple murder
investigation with the news that the
mother of the two children that died in
the fire at this flat has passed away in
hospital this morning she's been named
fatimata haidara aged 28 we knew that
she'd been in a critical condition since
this fire took hold in the early hours
of Sunday morning but very sadly has now
passed away now police have also told us
the names of her two young children who
died in the immediate aftermath of that
fire Neymar drama aged just one and her
older sister Fatima drami who was just
three years old the police have released
images of the girls and the heartbroken
family of of those girls and indeed
fatimata have shared some video of the
two young girls with us which shows the
two playing together as happy young
sisters would play together this was uh
neighbors and family tellers a very
happy young family living here at this
flat in Nottingham
that video there you can see the little
toddler naimo drame
playing with her older sister Fatima it
is just heartbreaking for the family to
have to come to terms not only with
their deaths but now also the fact that
their mother 28 year old mother has
passed away to in this fire now the
other shocking element to this is that
this is being treated as a deliberate a
fire that was started deliberately
that's why this is a murder
investigation a 31 year old man from the
local area who was arrested
on Sunday evening police telling us they
now have been given an additional 36
hours to interview him so he's now being
questioned on suspicion of three murders
and we've had some words from detective
Chief Inspector Mark zinski who's
leading the investigation I'll read you
what he says he says we're dealing with
one of the most horrendous crimes the
death of two young children and their
mother this is a deeply upsetting
tragedy and I can only imagine the
family's pain they include the woman's
husband and father of the two children
who is not in the UK at the time of the
fire both he and other members of the
family are being supported by specially
trained officers at this incredibly
difficult time and we asked for the
media to give them privacy while they
deal with this incredible loss he goes
on to say this has been an extremely
traumatic event for them and I'd like to
reassure them we're doing everything we
possibly can to bring them the Justice
they deserve we know that the the
husband and father of the victims was
here actually in this street yesterday
after he'd flown in from America he was
just utterly shell-shocked and went to
the hospital to be by his wife's bedside
but sadly we've learned now that she has
also lost her life in this fire I was
just chatting to a neighbor who said
what a lovely family they were how sad
everyone is and how they simply can't
understand why anyone would want to hurt
them
Becky Johnson thanks very much for
bringing us that update